(clicking)
(rock music)
- [Narrator] Fear on stage.
Let's talk stage fright for a second.
- [Meg Mac] I mean I'm
scared the whole time
I'm up there in a way.
Most of the time I'm on stage
I just want to be, like, hidden.
Like, I don't even want
to be visible, you know.
- [Leon Bridges] You know, I like
to drink whiskey before I get on stage.
If I'm like sober up there I'm
just like awkward and weird.
- [Halsey] What if I walk
out there and I can't?
There's a possibility that I can walk
on that stage and this could suck.
I could not sing, I could
freak out, I could panic.
- [Alt-J] You feel like
you can't trust your body
to do the most basic movements
that you've grown up doing.
And it's like vertigo,
that's how I always describe stage-fright.
- [Hozier] So at first my throat
used to close up on stage.
You can't really breath
and you can't really sing,
you know, fuck that you have to do it.
You just have to walk through that fire
and come out the other end.
(static)
- [Narrator] That's exactly what I needed.
Good.
(static)
(light music)